this is a production of cornell
university
thank you lydia um and i just want to um
also just appreciate all of the work
that libya has done organizing this
session it's been great working with her
and i think we've got some great
information for you here today
so i'm going to start us off by talking
about recognizing common natural enemies
of pests because we felt like this was
information that would be relevant
throughout the rest of the session
um
so i have basically just two goals for
today's talk i want to go over just a
couple of definitions make sure we're
all on the same page so that throughout
the rest of the session
i and other speakers aren't throwing
around terms and you're not sure what
they mean and then we're going to spend
the rest of our time practicing
recognizing some common natural enemies
of pests
as lydia mentioned you can ask questions
in the chat at any time um i do have my
chat window up and i can see it while
i'm watching the slide so i'll try to
keep an eye on that
and
as we appreciate all of your
participation already in that zoom poll
i will ask you to continue to
participate today so just consider
yourselves fairly warned on that
all right and so here's your first
opportunity to participate when you hear
the term natural enemy what comes to
mind i'd like you to go ahead and find
that chat button if you don't see it you
might need to hover over either the
bottom or the top of your screen go
ahead and click on that chat button and
type your answer in and hit enter
and i'm just curious what you think
about when you hear natural enemy
so responses that we got
were good bugs and i think that's a good
way to describe natural enemies
um
so what is a natural enemy it's related
to this concept of bio control or
biological control
biological control just means using
something living to control pests and
bio control is just a short way of
saying that
so
ladybugs and aphids or lady beetles and
aphids are commonly thought of as an
example of bio control and in that
example the natural enemy or the
bio-control agent is the good bug the
lady beetle that is eating the pest
which is the aphid in this situation
this is also a good time for me to
mention especially if there's some
entomologists on the call
throughout today's talk i will be using
the term bug a little bit loosely so
entomologists know the bug has a very
specific meaning but everyone who's not
an entomologist tends to use bug just to
mean something creepy crawly
so although
insects have six legs and spiders and
mites have eight legs and so technically
we might call them all together
arthropods throughout this talk i'll
probably use the term bug to refer to
both insects and other arthropods
so there are a few different types of
natural enemies natural enemies can be
predators not pretty most of us are
familiar with the concept of a predator
so the insect biocontrol agent is
catching and eating a pest or maybe
feeding the pest to their young
lady beetles are a great example of
predators but also spiders ground
beetles and there are some wasps and a
whole lot of other insects that are
predators also
there are also parasitoid natural
enemies and i'm not going to say
anything else about this because lydia's
going to cover parasitoids in our next
talk
and she's got some great
images and videos for you about that
and there are beneficial nematodes that
are natural enemies and you're going to
hear from kyle wickings about that a
little bit later in today's session
today we will not be talking about
herbivores which would be insects that
eat plant pests although there are
certainly some natural enemies that do
that um and some people we often we
think about natural enemies we think
about insects bugs um
technically natural enemies could also
be microbes we're not going to talk
about that side of biocontrol either
today
um especially not in this talk i think
uh our final speaker sam holden will
touch it a little bit
all right so now we're all on the same
page with definitions let's get
to some practice of recognizing some
common natural enemies
and i like to do this with the good bug
bad bug game
because this is more interesting for all
of us so the way we're going to do this
is something that is called a waterfall
in the chat so i'll ask you a question
i'll show you a picture and you're gonna
tell me if it looks like a good bug a
bad bug or a neutral bug
and you're gonna type your response into
the chat but you're gonna wait and i'm
gonna give you a countdown three two one
and everyone's gonna enter at the same
time what that will do is that you'll
see this kind of waterfall of responses
and then you don't have to worry so much
about if your answer is right or wrong
because no one's paying attention to who
gave the answer we're just seeing these
this list of responses go by
all right
let's get started
okay so here's your first picture we've
got a um shiny insect it's got mostly
red covers in its wings with some black
spots a black and white head does this
look like a good bug a bad bug or a
neutral bug
i'll give folks a moment to send
me a direct message
someone asked if this was a trick
question it's not a trick question i
want to start off with an easy one
set you all up for success
yeah i'm seeing uniformly everyone is
saying yep this is a good bug
and you are all correct
um so this is the lady beetle also
called the lady bug also called the lady
bird beetle
these are natural enemies that eat a lot
of soft bodied pests including aphids
white flies syrups mites
um
eggs of insects the adults can also feed
on pollen or nectar and there are a lot
of different species of ladybugs and
they come in different colors and
sometimes different shapes so this pink
spotted lady
lady beetle ladybug
is not quite the classic ladybug shape
and look that this seven spotted lady
beetle is
it's actually a species that's native to
new york
um there is also uh so here's a picture
of a checkered spotted lady beetle not
native but still a natural enemy
multi-colored asian lady beetles if you
have had lady beetles that are in your
house that are a pest in a structure it
was probably a multi-colored asian lady
beetle they're still natural enemies
they still eat pests however they can be
a bit of a nuisance inside you can
distinguish them because if you look on
this part of the insect it's called the
pronodum you'll see an m
i don't think it stands for multicolored
but that's how i remember
all right what about this one this
insect is black and orange it's a little
bit spiky
this look like a good bug a bad bug or a
neutral bug
seeing some responses coming in
most of the responses are saying this is
a good bug and i would agree with that
so this is actually the same insect it's
also a lady beetle lady beetles look
very different when they're immature
larvae though compared to when they're
adults
so here are two different species of
lady beetle larvae they tend to be a
little bit spiky they're often black and
orange or maybe black and yellow
and they have these kind of elongated
bodies
they are great predators when they are
larvae and then they go into a resting
stage called pupa or pube if there's
many of them multiples of them
and they just sit there they don't do
anything they attach to leaves they
attach to other surfaces but it's
important that you are able to recognize
these so that you don't see them and
think this is a pest you have to do
something about
spiders and harvest men are another good
bug
not technically an insect but a good bug
they will eat a whole range of
arthropods including some beneficials so
oops
this spider here is actually eating the
small bee which is unfortunate for the
bee but that is the way nature works
they depending on the species they might
also feed on nectar or pollen
so the difference between a spider and a
harvestman is the body shape so this
spider has a distinctive kind of
constricted waste between the head and
the body
the harvestmen does have a head and a
body but it looks like it's just one
single blob
all right what about this one this is a
green insect
with
wings that are kind of look like nets
all right most of the responses that are
coming in are saying good
i'm going to ask you about one more
insect before
i give you the answer
i like the emoji response that's
excellent
um
so here's another insect this one is
kind of shaped like a lady beetle larva
it has got really big jaws if you can't
tell this is the head of the insect
those are its jaws it's kind of brown
and pale yellow does this look like a
good insect a bad insect
or something neutral
most of the responses coming in are
saying good and i would agree with you
this is another situation where the two
different life stages of this insect
look very different so here's an adult
lace wing this one's green although some
are brown and this is a larval lace wing
looks completely different and those
jaws look kind of intimidating but those
jaws are for eating insects not for
hurting you i suppose if you bothered it
it might give you a little pinch but it
wouldn't hurt much
so lace wings also eat aphids mites
thrips white flies other small insects
um all of the larvae are predators in
some species the adults are predators
also
and the adults will feed on pollen and
nectar too and here's a larva that's
hanging out on a flower the other thing
to note about lace wings is it's good to
know what the eggs look like so lace
wing eggs are always at the end of long
stocks so if you see these on your farm
then that's a good sign you have some
lace wings that will be hatching soon
i'm not going to spend a lot of time on
wasps except to say that my rule of
thumb for wasps is that if it's not
hurting anyone leave it alone so
obviously if you have a nest of yellow
jackets or hornets that's in a space
where they're going to be contacting
people and they could be stinging them
you have to do something about that but
if they are someplace away from people
where they're not posing a stinging risk
these yellow jackets and other social
wasps are actually good predators
they'll eat lots of insects
there's a lot of solitary wasps that are
very very unlikely to sting you and
their parasite wasps which lydia will
talk about shortly
what about this one
good bug bad bug or neutral it's got
this kind of distinctive pale yellow and
brown striping pattern with some diamond
shapes on its back
i'm seeing a mix of responses coming in
some people aren't quite sure some
neutral some bad
i suppose it could depend on what you're
growing so this is a tarnish plant bug
and they can definitely cause damage on
some plants including fruits and flowers
they so here's some tarnished plant bugs
they're actually damaging a coreopsis
flower you can't so much see here but
the flowers misshapen
and they can damage strawberries and
some other crops as well so if the
tarnished plant bugs are something that
could be damaging your crop then they
would be a bad bug
as far as i know they have no particular
benefit um so if they're if you have a
crop that tarnished plant bugs aren't a
problem then they could be neutral in
that setting
what about this one this one i will tell
you is a zoomed in magnified picture
uh it has kind of black it's black
towards the front and then it's got sort
of a white triangle towards its rear
it's got eyes that stick out on the side
of its head
and
got a pointy nose
seeing a mixture of
good bug and bad bug responses here
this is a mining pirate bug and these
are good bugs they are very tiny they're
no more than a quarter of an inch long
and just for a size comparison this is a
zoomed in picture of the center of a
cosmos flower and here's a minute pirate
bug on that flower so very very small
they will eat other small insects like
aphids mite strips
and some insect eggs both the adults
that are black and white here
and the nymphs that are bright orange
are predators and they can also feed on
pollen nectar which is one reason that
if you have um
flowers that have produced a lot of
pollen um
growing near your crops you might see
minor pirate bugs on those plants
and then i have a little video of a my
new pirate bug running around the maze
um running around a map of a corn maze
that was kind of the most exciting part
of the corn maze for me was finding my
new pirate buds
all right what about this one
good bug bad bug or neutral it's got
really big eyes
it's got just one pair of wings
and its body is black and yellow striped
i'm seeing a lot of good responses come
into the chat
some neutrals
some question marks
this one is a hover fly also called a
surfeit fly and for this insect the
adults will
feed on pollen and nectar and they're
important pollinators so they're
visiting some flowers here and the
larvae are great predators especially in
aphids but also white flies and scales
some people think they look a little bit
like bees and some species really do
like this one that has a fatter body
however they have bigger eyes they have
just two wings whereas bees have four
they are black and yellow often like
these and if you watch them outside they
do have a distinctive hovering pattern
especially around flowers
there are a whole lot more predatory and
parasitoid flies that i'm not going to
cover today
partly because their identification is a
little bit tricky and partly because we
just don't have time
um this group the surfaids are pretty
easy to identify um and so i like to
include them
and i want to tell you about two other
natural enemies that you're they're
probably in your soil that are sometimes
hard to notice unless you're looking
very carefully for them
so row of beetles which if you have a
greenhouse it's possible that you've
used some rove beetles in your
greenhouse for bio control
these eat a lot of different soil
invertebrates including slugs and snails
and also
drips and some insect eggs some of them
will also eat seeds
the way to distinguish them if you get a
close look is these are actually the
hard wing covers like a lady beetle
would have on its back but instead of
covering the whole abdomen they only
cover the first part of the abdomen and
here's those short wing covers here too
i think it kind of makes the beetle look
like it's wearing a little cape
carabid beetles are a really large group
of insects they will eat a whole lot of
different arthropods as well as snails
and slugs and seeds including weed seeds
most of them live on the ground and they
tend to have really prominent jaws which
you can see well in this picture here
they're often brown or black um at least
on top these tiger beetles are kind of
iridescent green underneath and they're
generally very fast a lot of carabid
beetles will actually chase down their
prey like a cheetah you can kind of
think of them as the cheetah of the
insect world
this was certainly not an exhaustive
list there are a lot of other natural
enemies out there i wanted to focus on
some of the natural enemies that are the
easiest to identify um and some common
ones um i will post some links in the
chat
um after my talk uh where you can find
some more information about
identification
um and one of the resources that will be
linked is this app called i naturalist
and you can actually take pictures of
thanks lydia you can take pictures of
insects with this app or plants as well
and it will try to identify the insect
or the plant from the picture or it'll
tell you it can't tell from that picture
it's not perfect but it's a good place
to start it can give you more
information for um doing a further
search also um please take advantage of
your local extension experts
all right we're going to do one more
poll question so this is kind of to see
what you have learned
um
go ahead and launch this
so i've got some pictures up here i've
got 10 different insects and they're all
labeled a b c d e f g h i j so on the
pole if you could mark all of the
letters that are natural enemies
um
that would be great and i'll i'll go
ahead and tell you up front we ended up
not covering this j insect so you can
skip that one this is a leaf hopper just
so you know
so i'll give folks a moment to respond
to that question
and i will go ahead and
put some links in the chat
while you all are responding
um this one is a pocket guide to natural
enemies that you can print out yourself
it's free online
and i'm also going to post
links to two blog posts i've written
that go over this information so if you
want to refer back to it later
it's pretty similar information that
i've covered in these blog posts here
all right i know that we need to move on
to the next speaker so
um i am going to show you what the
answers were so everything here is a
natural enemy except for this tarnish
plant bug here and this leaf hopper over
here
with that i appreciate your time and
hope you enjoy the rest of the session
all right
so i'll get into my presentation
um so again welcome everyone thank you
for being here my name is lydia camandi
i'm a phd candidate in the department of
entomology
today i'm going to discuss parasitoid
wasps the body snatchers of the insect
world
and a little bit about their biology
ecology and how to support local
populations
so to outline some of the topics i'm
going to discuss first um we'll touch on
what makes an insect a parasitoid
um we'll learn then how to recognize
them in the field we'll discuss how they
can be used in agricultural settings
relevant to you and how to uh attract
and support populations
and so if you have any questions at any
time during the presentation don't
hesitate to drop it in the chat
um so just to give some definitions
before i get into it i'm going to be
talking about eggs larvae pupae and
adults and so i just want to explain
that in the context of eggs i'm talking
about clutches of insect eggs right here
when i talk about larvae i'm basically
talking about little caterpillars or
worm-like insects as they are developing
they're the immature version of insects
i'll be talking about pupae which are
basically like the chrysalis of a
butterfly when it's developing
before it becomes an adult and then
obviously adult insects as you can see
here
so to begin amara did a great job of
explaining the benefits that natural
enemies bring to our ecosystems and in
this presentation i'm going to focus
specifically on parasitoid wasps
which are a type of natural enemy
however i did want to define a few
different types of organisms that fall
under this broad umbrella of natural
enemies or beneficial organisms
um this can include insects such as
beetles here
wasps um arachnids like spiders or mites
nematodes
viruses and beneficial bacteria
predators like mantids
and then to begin
you know a parasitoid is often an insect
that facilitates the development of
their young on or within the body of
another host in this case it's often
insects tests
aphids are a really common example of
insects that are targeted um or targets
of parasitism by parasitoid wasps
um but parasitoid behavior by insects is
thought to be really one of the most
gruesome behaviors in the animal kingdom
um and was even used to write the plot
of the alien movies and so i'll get into
that a little bit later and why
um so parasitoids which are often
insects in general have characteristics
of both predators and parasites they
hunt their prey and they attack however
a pretty large or significant difference
between parasitoids and true predators
is that parasitoids don't kill and
consume their victims
instead they lay eggs within the body
cavity
and so the eggs then develop into larvae
and consume the host insects organs
slowly and carefully um while allowing
it to live until they're pretty much
ready to emerge which is pretty creepy
and when insects are targeted by
parasitoids their offspring develop um
in you know within the insect body
sometimes within the body and then they
come out and pupit outside of the body
um and so you can see in these pictures
the craziest part about these parasitoid
offspring is that they're very careful
not to kill their insect host until the
most opportune time which allows them
enough time to fully develop into adult
wasps
and lastly
there are parasitoids that target really
every life stage of the insect from the
egg to adulthood so nobody is really
safe from parasitism
it's important to note that there are
multiple species
of insects that can parasitize living
hosts from beetles to flies and wasps
however parasitoid wasps happen to be
the most abundant successful and that
diverse
group of parasitoids so we'll just be
focusing on them for the remainder of
the talk
um so here's a little bit of background
information on parasitoid wasps
earlier um they're beneficial insects as
they're able for populations of insect
pests
um there are over 60 000 named species
of parasite wasps and the estimated
number of undescribed species is over
600 000
which really speaks to the size and the
diversity of parasitoid wasps as a group
in terms of insects in general about 10
to 25 percent are thought to be
parasitoids
with wasps comprising the largest group
of parasitoids but
to consider the vastness of this
behavior it's hypothesized that
for every insect pest there's at least
one parasitoid species that is
biologically synchronized to parasite
parasitize that pest
so in terms of identifying parasitoid
wasps in your region there's really no
tried or true rule
other than the presence of maybe a wasp
waste
because they can be very diverse in size
color and even with their markings
um
however they don't look like a typical
paper wasp or a b with the yellow and
black striped markings um they're often
like you can see here black or brown
their whole body is black or brown and
they have the presence of an ovipositor
and nova positor is here in red it's a
fancy name for
a modified stinger or organ
that's basically a tube that delivers
the females eggs
and they're deposited into the victims
and they're also used to impale their
victims
and so that's how the wasps lay their
eggs
um because oval positors are part of the
female reproductive system female wasps
are responsible for 100 of the
parasitism behavior
um and unlike some of their aunt bee or
wasp cousins parasitoid wasps don't live
in new social colonies like bee colonies
they're solitary can often be seen
flying alone searching for nectar which
is what the adults feed on
or looking for hosts to parasitize
so like amara mentioned in her
presentation eye naturalist is a really
good app you can use to identify
parasitoid wasps or other natural
enemies
it's one of my favorites because it's
also used to identify plants and other
animals not just insects
but bug guide is also a website that you
could take advantage of or like mara
mentioned your local experts
um so i've talked a little bit about the
fact that pearson waps can parasitize
every stage of an insect's life
but i wanted to give you an idea of the
life cycle and the process
um because i think it's pretty cool so
first um the female wasp usually mates
to fertilize her eggs with a male wasp
um she then searches for a viable host
so in this case she would be looking for
insect egg clutches this could be stink
bug eggs
usually that's a pretty common parasite
it's kind of like a russian nesting doll
of parasitization because the female
wasp lays her egg within the egg of
another insect
and then she leaves her offspring to
develop without her and they begin to
develop within the host's egg consuming
the tissue of the original host and then
emerging when their development is
complete and what's interesting about
larval parasitoids in particular similar
to egg parasitoids
is that the female wasp locates a live
larval host which makes it just a little
bit more gruesome and personal
but they behave similarly to egg
parasitoids
so now i have a video to show you guys
we know if you have volume
this wriggling little guy is a baby
recanted wasp
it's bursting out of a cottonwood dagger
caterpillar and starting to spin a
cocoon
believe it or not this somewhat gruesome
scene is part of a healthy balanced
ecosystem
until now the caterpillar served as the
wasps food and nursery
recon and wasps are parasitoids that
means they first infect but eventually
kill their host animals to survive
regular parasites generally don't kill
their hosts outright
the cycle begins when a parasitoid lays
eggs inside or on the caterpillar or on
top of the caterpillar's food
as the larvae hatch and grow they feed
on the caterpillar's internal organs
they often save the most important parts
for last to keep their host alive
some parasitoids like this tachnid fly
grow to nearly the same size as their
hosts before bursting out
after emerging from the caterpillar
these parasitoids pupate and develop
into adults
then they search for a new host to lay
eggs starting the cycle over
parasitoids have a special purpose
they keep their host populations in
check
without them the caterpillar population
could skyrocket out of control and
destroy the trees that they eat
some parasitoids are used to help
control invasive species and pests that
otherwise could devastate the
environment
so they can help keep the ecosystem
healthy
sometimes helpful things come in
wriggling packages
[Music]
okay so hopefully you're not too grossed
out by that video
um
so now that we have a complete picture
of how parasitoid wasps live and
reproduce and you've got all the visuals
we want to know how they can be used in
agriculture
um so we know that they're able to
reduce insect pest populations
um
and they're known to do this in a range
of habitats worldwide this behavior has
really become a point of focus for
biocontrol experts
and it could be implemented in
agricultural systems in the future
pretty successfully
but in addition to agricultural services
parasitoid wasps
serve as pollinators um and they're not
exactly
as efficient at pollinating as bees
because they don't have a lot of the
fuzzy hairs that are responsible for
taking pollen from flower to flower
but they still are pollinators um
because the
adult wasps feed on nectar and can take
that pollen from plant to plant
um despite that um
there are some little fun facts here so
it has been shown that parasitoids are
able to get here
um they're able to pick up plant cues
via chemicals called volatiles
and this is basically when the plant is
telling them that a pest is present and
can help them spot and parasitize
insect pests more effectively
so the next four slides really just
contain examples of parasitoid wasp
species that may be of value to you
depending on what pest problems you have
if any of you have green stink bugs or
really any sink bug problem you may
benefit from populations of trosulcus
basalis which is a parasitoid of stink
bugs
um and it's an egg parasitoid like i
mentioned earlier
the stink bug the green stink bug is a
pest of many cool crops nightshades
specialty crops flowering plants and
grasses so you would benefit from
increased parasitism of their eggs in
your garden greenhouse or crop field by
this parasitoid
the allium leaf miner is a pest of many
high-value allium crops um and the
parasitoid helicopter circulation may
help reduce populations of pupating
flies which can help reduce yield loss
however i should note that this species
of parasitoid is not found abundantly
here yet but that could change with
increased bio-controlled programs
the leak moth parasitoid similar to the
allium leaf miter parasitoid diadromous
is also a very efficient parasitoid of
the pupil form of the leak moth which is
also a pest of alliums
um and lastly the european corn bore
parasitoid erebors terra brance is a
really effective parasite against the
european corn borer which is a major
pest of field and sweet corn varieties
these are just a few examples of
parasitoids that target insect pests
just in this region so if you're
interested in parasitoid wasps or pests
and you're struggling to control them
you can always search for information
online like cornell's biological control
website
um or you can contact local experts like
amara for more information
um which leads to my next slide yes they
are available for commercial commercial
purchase
um so
gopher
planet natural and arbico organics are
just a few of the companies that are
currently rearing and selling some
species of parasitoid wasps
however i should note that these
applications are primarily intended for
greenhouse use so you can retain these
populations
um and amara will be including a few
links to these companies in the chat
maybe after the presentation or during
um so if you're looking to support
populations if you don't do any
greenhouse work um in your garden or
fields here are a few tips um
in to welcome these beneficial wasps
um so the first is providing an adequate
source of water this can really
encourage beneficial insect populations
not just parasitoid wasps
um and this can be in the form of bird
baths ponds creeks even ditches on your
property
second is maintaining floral resources
for the wasps like i said the adults
feed on nectar
and they rely on these flowers
throughout the summer to sustain their
populations so that could really help
and lastly
is habitat providing some non-crop
habitat for these wasps
to forage for nectar is really helpful
and it can encourage populations but
more importantly populations of other
beneficial insects not just parasitic
wasps
so in addition to providing resources
for parasitoid wasps it's important to
make sure that if you're managing your
crops your management tactics are
compatible with parasitoid wasps and
other beneficials so insecticides are
often not compatible with beneficial
insects as the ingredients formulated to
kill them are the
same as the ingredients formulated to
kill the pests
um so for this reason you should use
insecticides as a last-ditch effort when
you've really exhausted all other
management tactics
but if you do have questions about the
insecticide risks um to non-target
beneficial organisms of the products
you're using you can refer to
the eiq of the product you're curious
about
um the eiq is the environmental impact
quotient which is
basically based on a formula
that's been created to determine
the impact
a product has on the environment or
natural enemies so for more information
on the eiq you can refer to the new york
state ipm page which tomorrow will also
link
um and this will give more information
about eiq's and how they're used um and
in addition to that you know always read
product labels carefully and follow all
recommendations that's the best advice
can give
um and so
as a takeaway for the presentation
although some periscope was species are
very successful at reducing pest
populations
um parasitoid wasps are not a complete
cure for severe pest outbreaks um
instead they're just a tool in the ipm
toolbox that should be used in
conjunction with other tactics if
necessary
and in summary um we defined some
parasitoids we learned how to recognize
them and identify them
we examined how they're used to control
pests in the most gruesome way possible
and how to attract and support these
populations so we can keep them around
year after year
um so with that i'd like to thank amara
dunn brian nolt and kyle wickings for
their oversight on this project um the
extension outreach assistantship program
through the department of entomology for
funding me um and then the null lab for
their feedback and support and you guys
for listening let me know if you have
any questions
you can drop them in the chat or you can
unmute yourself
that's great lydia thank you um i i know
there was an avalanche of um messages in
the chat with links um one of them also
included a link to a google document
where we have all the links from today's
session um so that if um that's an easy
place for you to get your hands on the
resources that we've been sharing during
the talks
all right well then if there's no
questions i will welcome
kyle wickings he's our next up presenter
he's assistant professor of soil
arthropod ecology and turf grass
entomology here at corn hill agritech
and he's going to be talking about
nematodes today take it away kyle all
right well i hope you're all enjoying
looking at
larvae popping out of larvae and all
that cool stuff we're going to talk a
little bit more about that now um
so as lydia said i'm i'm kyle wickings
i'm the turfgrass entomologist here at
cornell and i'm a soil ecologist so i do
a lot of work with below ground animals
and insects and part of that work
involves managing below ground pests um
there's a lot of below ground pests and
turf grasses actually most of the ones
we deal with feed on roots and and below
ground parts of plants but
what we'll talk about today i think
carries across just about any commodity
where you've got below ground pests that
you're trying to manage so
some of my research program focuses on
using what we call biocontrol nematodes
or entomopathogenic nematodes and that's
what we're going to talk about
specifically today we'll sort of get
into their biology and their their
ecology
and talk about strategies for using them
to control critters that plague your
crops below ground so
i wanted to start just by talking about
the basics of nematodes because i think
there's a lot of confusion about them
and misconceptions about what nematodes
are
so the place to start is just in their
overwhelming abundance this is probably
the most abundant animal on earth and
they're incredibly numerous in a lot of
different ecosystems and over 80 percent
of animal life that you encounter on
earth is a nematode so
um
and especially in soils they really
really do well in soil as a habitat and
there can be over two million of them in
a single square foot of soil which is
hard hard to picture and hard to fathom
but there's a really good reason we
don't recognize this and that's because
of their small size so they're they're
pretty much microscopic organisms
typically less than a millimeter long
so very easy to overlook but what they
lack in size they make up for in numbers
beyond their numbers they're incredibly
diverse from species to species some of
them are really important crop pests and
i think this is where a lot of the
confusion comes in because when you hear
a recommendation to try using nematodes
to manage a pest you often think about
nematodes that have
been pests in their own right in in the
crops that you work in
nematodes like sting and lance nematode
and the golden nematode they can be
really important
pests of plants but we're talking about
a whole other species and range of
ecological group of nematodes here so
they're very very different
but just to kind of i guess
set the stage there to talk about how
broad they can be ecologically i think
that's important to know
but nematodes can also be predators they
can feed on bacteria and fungi but then
there's this really unique group the
entomopathogens or insect pathogens and
that's what we're going to focus on
today
so it gets that name because entomo
means insect and it's not really a
pathogen but that's sort of the name
that's stuck with them
um
the entomopathogenic nematode itself is
not just the nematode but it's also
these bacteria that live in the gut of
the organism and without the symbiosis
between the bacteria and the nematode
the biocontrol function wouldn't
actually happen so you're really talking
about multiple organisms that have a
symbiotic relationship to make this
function work
and if you think about it the nematode
they're really really mobile in soil
they're kind of like aquatic organisms
and they can move very very well soil
matrix if it's moist
and they're kind of the vehicle for
moving these bacteria around and as
you'll see on the next slide it's really
the bacteria that do the the killing so
the grody part
so this is the generalized life cycle
for entomopathogenic nematodes and we'll
walk through it just from the top
starting with this nematode at station
number one
um
so
there's a life stage for these nematodes
where the the individuals are free
living in the soil and they're really
mobile at that point they rely on water
films to swim around and move and seek
out hosts but they contain that
symbiotic bacteria in their gut at that
point so they're moving around with that
symbiont in their gut looking for an
insect host
and they can find those hosts through a
lot of different means typically they'll
use chemical cues to find them
and when they do they'll colonize the
organism
and you know i guess sticking in that
theme of nasty interactions this is
another one so they'll swim through the
the mouth the anus the sphericals where
the insects breathe through to enter the
body and when they're in there they'll
release these symbiotic bacteria into
the insect so these bacteria aren't all
the same thing and based on the species
of nematode you might have different
species of bacteria that live in the gut
and they're not bacteria that you
commonly find living free in the soil
they're actually very dependent upon
these nematodes so it's a really
important interaction for the bacteria
as well
so once inside we're talking about the
stage two over here once inside the
insect they'll release those bacteria
and the bacteria produce a toxin to kill
the insect
and at that point they release a whole
array of digestive enzymes to break that
insect cadaver down into
sort of a nutrient broth that they can
feed on
so we have all these bacteria that are
reproducing
um from that those nutrients they just
created by killing that insect and this
takes it can take five to ten days or so
for this death to happen for the insect
um kind of depends on the species and
the conditions but that's a rough
estimate of how long it takes
and then at that point the nematodes
will feed on the bacteria as they're
reproducing so they're sort of farming
their own food out of bacteria
after that the nematodes will reproduce
and then they will emerge out of the
cadaver in dramatic fashion so they sort
of burst out of these cadavers to go
find a new host and start the whole
process over again so that's the general
life cycle for this process
like i said until by the time we get
dead insects from you know infection to
their death they can take about five
to ten days which is important to think
about when you're
you know deciding whether or not this is
a useful tool for you if you need
something that will kill insects much
quicker this may not be the most
feasible so something to keep in mind
beyond that sort of shared life cycle
there's a lot of differences at the
species level and these nematodes and
it's important to talk about this
um because it really depends on the type
of pest you're trying to manage which
nematode you would select so
um as lydia was talking about in her
slides before me there's a lot of
commercial sources for these nematodes
and there's going to be three typical
species you see available from these
actually the same suppliers that lydia
mentioned
um
specifically for epns or
antimalpathogenic nematodes that control
soil dwelling pests so the species here
are heteroappditis bacteriophara this is
a mouthful so it's often abbreviated hb
or h bacteriophage
and the others are steiner nema feltii
and steiner nema carpal kapsy so
you'll often just see these abbreviated
and sometimes the abbreviations hb sf or
sc are incorporated right into the name
of the product so
keep an eye out for that if you're
looking through some of these products
so
aside from being annoying to pronounce
there's some really important ecology
among these species that really impacts
your selection of a nematode if you want
to control a particular pest so and just
to kind of draw attention to that in
some of the most extreme cases we have
some entomopathogenic nematodes that
live really shallow in the soil and they
stay very localized so you might use a
nematode like this such as steiner
pneumocarpal capsi to control an insect
pest that's right at the soil surface or
just below the soil surface kind of up
in the crowns and the roots
upper root zone of the plants
and we they're often referred to as kind
of like an ambush predator but they
mostly just will stay somewhat localized
in their activity so
now that might not be the best nematode
to use for a mobile deep dwelling pest
like these scarab beetles or white grubs
this is this is a pest that my lab works
with a lot in turf grasses so for a pest
like that you would want a much more
mobile and a much deeper dwelling
nematode like the heterodyne of
nematodes so
you'll see language on the labels for
these commercial products talking about
which pests they'll control
and the product should be listing the
actual nematode species as well so you
can reference that but just to point out
that it's a it's actually you really
want to pair the nematode well with the
the pest that you're looking to manage
so really important step
um here's another list some of this
crosses over with what lydia pointed out
and some web links and i can get some of
this information to amara as well if you
want to post more but there are a lot of
places to order entomopathogenic
nematodes from and we'll talk about some
of the pros and cons and what you
actually need to look for when you get
them
um in a bit but just to point out you'll
see a lot of vendors for these some of
these producers create their own
nematodes and have processes for rearing
them in their facilities others will buy
nematodes produced by someone else and
repackage them for sale so but these are
some of the the really common ones i've
got posted here
and typically you'll see nem somewhere
in the name when they're uh
i want to talk a little bit about
formulation and mixing because you can
get these things it's very different
than you know looking at um some of the
much more charismatic bio-control agents
because you don't really see the
nematode when you buy it you're buying
something that looks like a chunk of
sponge or a packet of gel beads
and it's really hard to know you know
what's actually in there so i think it
helps to orient everybody to you know
what is the material you actually get
the nematodes in
so sponge material is used often the
nematodes will be packed into that
sponge and you just wash them out with
water
there are a number of
different types of granules and pellets
that they'll pack nematodes in and this
helps protect the nematodes during
shipping and keeps them preserved
later on
um and most of that is water dispersable
material
there's also you'll find them also in
gels and vermiculite and you you really
don't choose that it's sort of what the
facility uses to pack their product and
to increase its longevity so but there's
a lot of variability in what you which
will get them packed in
and unopened across the board for these
different materials
you'll see differences on the packages
in terms of how long they'll tell you
you can store them but it's very easy to
get them to last for months and we've
found that unopened as long as they're
not opened up you can get them to last
at least a month up to two
so it is different than some of the
chemical options that we have out there
which can be stored easily for months on
the shelf there's a much shorter time
clock on these things so something else
to keep in mind
once the packages are open regardless of
the style here it's the the clock gets
even shorter and it is something that
you want to use relatively quickly and
that's especially true for once they're
mixed with water you really don't want
to mix them
uh with water until you're absolutely
ready to go and make an application and
even then you want to use that material
within about two hours of having mixed
it together so something to keep in mind
is just thinking about how does this
compare
in my my timeline compared to how i
might use a chemical option
um
when you get the product there's usually
pretty good information on the package
as to how to handle it and you'll see
language on the on these packages
referring to refrigeration some
nematodes
it will have instructions saying just to
keep them in a cool dark place but
typically refrigeration is the main step
to improve their longevity and shelf
life
um they'll also list used by dates on
there as well mostly for if you haven't
opened it yet but some will also talk
about how long you can keep it after
you've opened it and they're general
guidelines and they're usually pretty
conservative too
but you'll also see the packages talk
about limiting exposure especially to uv
and temperature extremes because those
they're very uv sensitive
um
and also temperatures above 100
fahrenheit and below freezing will
definitely kill the nematodes so that's
why refrigeration is probably the best
bet
but even if you have all the boxes
checked on these factors and
everything's good it's really important
to check the viability of these products
when you buy them and it sounds like a
daunting thing like how do i get this
pack of vermiculite and find nematodes
in it it's actually not that difficult
so
what we do in our lab is we'll often
take a open the bag take a very very
tiny scoop i mean like if you're going
to sample a hot sauce and use a
toothpick something like that like just
a very tiny amount mix it in with a half
a mug of
coffee mug of water lukewarm water stir
it up and let it sit for about an hour
and then we will take a little bit of
that material and look at it under a
hand lens and you should be able to see
the nematodes in it they're going to be
small but you should still be able to
see them we'll use a microscope in our
lab but you can get by with a
decent quality hand lens as well
so
the nematodes should be waving in
appearance sort of had a lot of s-curves
in them or be spiraled up and you should
be able to actually see them wriggling
not
thrashing violently but wiggling a
little bit in the in the water
and that's a good sign they're alive and
active you will also see dead nematodes
in there and they have kind of a
hang nail appearance to them and they
won't be moving at all
there are occasions where you'll get
entire packages of nematodes that are
almost all dead and that's not obviously
intentional on the vendor's part but
it's something that you want to check on
because if you do all this work
to select the right nematode for the
pest time it right and all that you want
to make sure you're about to apply a
live
product to the field so so check it um
if the majority of them are dead then
you just contact the company they will
quickly overnight you a new batch to
work with so really important thing to
check and i'm happy to talk to anybody
who wants to reach out about that
process because it's not as difficult as
it might sound
um i want to talk next about application
because this is another step that i
think people assume must be really
complicated like it's a live organism
you're trying to apply these things it's
got to be a lot more complicated than a
chemical and it really is not so
you'll see on the packages a range of
different instructions
some just say to put them out with a
watering can and then water them in with
a garden hose it kind of depends on the
scale you're trying to do it if you're
looking at a commercial field that's not
the most practical
but you can use just about any equipment
you've got available to get
entomopathogenic nematodes applied
so here's an example of us using a small
co2 sprayer that will apply in small
plot studies it can also be used at sort
of a garden scale in the home lawn scale
you'll see rigs with electric pumps um
[Music]
on the back of pickup trucks and again
just about any type of a sprayer setup
you have you can use with some general
guidelines you want to follow so you
want
roughly
low pressure on these applicators not
low enough that it's going to affect how
well the application goes out
but
you want to make sure that it's at least
lower than 300 psi i don't have any
equipment that goes that high to be
honest but
just making sure you don't have anything
that's very high pressure because that
will shear the nematodes and kill them
as i mentioned on a couple slides back
you want to make sure that you're not
mixing these with water until you're
ready to apply so soon after you've
mixed it
get that material out
and you want to be able to agitate the
material as well because like a lot of
our products
nematodes will settle so they're aquatic
and they can swim but they really need a
water film if they have just a bucket of
water like you see in this
soda bottle here they'll just sink to
the bottom so
you either need to gently mix it like
we'll turn that bottle upside down
occasionally throughout the application
or actually have a proper agitator in
the tank and not an agitator that's
you're not trying to carbonate this
stuff you're really just trying to
gently mix it so
because too much and it will kill the
nematodes
there's a lot of different nozzles that
you can use
for making epn applications or animal
pathogen applications
you just want to make sure that if it
has screens in it it's a really large
gauge screen
or that you pull the screens up
completely
beyond that you want something that will
give you large droplet size but also
give you good coverage and there's a lot
of options for that so a decent flat fan
nozzle or a solid cone nozzle will do
that for you so
we'll often also use fertilizer stream
nozzles because you kind of get a dual
benefit you're putting the nematodes out
but you're putting it out in a very
saturated stream of water so it's almost
like you're irrigating at the same time
we you'll see lots of different
recommendations for the rates to apply
these nematodes at um so it'll say how
many nematodes come in the package on
average and then you will use that
number to determine your rate for for
the field you want to apply it on and we
recommend a billion per acre you'll see
different numbers there but a billion
per acre at least in the systems i work
in tends to be the density that
um a rate that gives you the most
consistent control so that is that's
where that recommendation comes from
i mentioned a couple slides back that
they're uv sensitive and that translates
to how we make our applications as well
so typically we try to make our
applications in donna dusk
dusk is best because you've got the
entire following evening for them to
settle into the soil before the sun is
beating back on the ground so
you can also capitalize on having
overcast days especially if they're
timed with a rain event because we it's
really important that you
provide water for the nematodes if it's
a saturated site already maybe a soil
that's at field capacity moisture you
might be fine but it is important to
provide water for the nematodes to move
into the soil
so we'll often if we have the luxury of
irrigation we don't always on the
systems i work in
we'll use that irrigation afterwards to
water the nematodes in
or like i said in the previous bullet
you can time it with with precipitation
when possible
so combine that gives the nematodes the
best chance of making it from that soil
surface into the pro soil profile down
to the roots where the pests are so
so i kind of want to
talk about this application approach a
little bit because everything we've
talked about so far especially with
commercial nematodes focuses on what i
would describe as somewhat of a curative
approach to management so think about
this is a pest i work with a lot so i
always show these slides think about
managing a pest when you know the pest
is there it's susceptible it's within a
window where you can use all the great
ipm tools of scouting decision making
and pest identification
which is great because typically this is
a great strategy for reducing how much
product you need
and making your applications just
fueled with decision so you have a lot
of
ammo there to make an accurate decision
but when it comes to bio control this
can also be risky because it's a fairly
narrow window of time this red band i've
animated over top of the box
and you don't know what the weather's
going to do within that time window and
you have to be very surgical to be able
to go and make those applications at
that time
so there's been some criticism of using
entomopathogenic nematodes in the
strategy because so much
depends on them being able to work in
that narrow window of time
and that's that's produced a lot of
results that are fairly mixed so cases
where they work really well cases where
they don't work so well and a lot of
questions about how we make them work
better so there's a lot of research
trying to improve that with commercial
nematodes but there's also another
approach that i wanted to just mention
because i think some of this is
happening in the vegetable world right
now that i think is just important for
everybody to know about so
rather than this very surgical curative
approach when the pest is present
there's also approach that we call
inoculative or
persistent use of entomopathogens so
this tends to focus more on using native
strains of nematodes and the idea being
that if you're working with native
nematodes they're a lot better adapted
to the ecosystem we have in new york
state so they're a lot more adapt to our
conditions here and the soil type that
we have and should be better able to
survive and perform in our system
so
um
elson shields here at cornell university
has been doing this in a lot of field
crops over the years and has kind of
been pioneering this area so i got very
interested in this and
started working with native
entomopathogenic nematodes when i joined
cornell so
the idea behind this though is that you
don't make an inoculation of these
nematodes
when a pest is present you try to get
them established in the system
so that by the time a pest is present
they're there and able to handle the
pest
and this depends on some things they're
that natural ability to weather the
harsh conditions that we have
particularly in new york state that we
throw at our critters um
also the ability to use other insects in
the soil as hosts to kind of bide their
time and survive in the soil so they're
flexible in their diet and their ecology
and this should result in a persistent
population that that's at that low level
kind of persisting
ready to do its job at any time so that
when you do have a pest emerge say an
outbreak of a root feeding pest like
white grubs the epns can infect and kill
it so a very very different approach
than that curative strategy
we've been doing this in a lot of
different systems it's actually a pretty
interesting and fairly low-tech approach
this is actually the process here these
nematodes are manually infected onto
insect larvae we buy these larvae from
bait suppliers that are very cheap
online
they get infected you rinse the
nematodes through a screen out of those
those infected larvae um and then we
screen it through a finer mesh screen
and it goes directly into our
application tank and this has been used
like i said with elsin and field crops
we're doing it on athletic fields
cemeteries um home lawns golf courses
sod farms
and more recently i've been told that
brian nalt has been collaborating with
elsin shields to explore this i think in
potato systems as well so there's a lot
a lot of people right now trying to dial
in this method for
for use of vpns
so um
i'm going to stop there and i know we're
right about at the time we got to switch
over so i can either take any questions
if people have them now or you're
welcome to follow up with me i'm pretty
easy to find at cornell and i'd love to
chat more if you have questions about
intimal pathogenic tools
so thanks for having me
yeah so the two links i dropped in the
chat um one
is a blog post
that basically just pulls together a lot
of resources about using epns there's
information there about the work elsin
shields has done with the persistent
nematodes and exactly how to do that all
those logistics
there's links to other resources
webinars to watch and then the second
link
is a direct link to a pdf document where
i tried to summarize what we know so far
about which vegetable pests epns work
against
because kyle did a great job of
summarizing the biology of how these
epns work and we want to provide a
little info about efficacy and vegetable
crops
um so our next speaker is sam wilbin
she's a phd candidate here also at
cornell agritech
and she's studying crop protection
specifically with low tunnel
strawberries she's a member of the
lowblab and today she'll be talking
about some of her research
thank you for the introduction i'm sam
wilden i work on protected culture of
strawberry today we're going to be
speaking about how uv selective films
can be used to improve efficacy of bio
pesticides so this bio pesticide could
include nematodes and but also other
antimo pathogens that you might spray in
the
field so this talk today is about
protected culture farming and
specifically growing under high and low
plastic tunnels so for protected culture
for this talk is more focused on tunnels
and not so much on greenhouses even
though sometimes those are lumped
together but we do see that growing
under growing specialty crops under
tunnels is an increasing trend in the
northeastern united states there are
many benefits that growers are reporting
when growing their crops under these
tunnels
and that includes protection against
wind rain and frost so protection from
the elements and this
becomes more important early in late
this season when weather is pretty
unpredictable
you also see that the tunnels maintain
warmer air and soil temperatures inside
of the tunnel and with that you can
actually extend the growing season of
strawberry and many other crops by
several weeks to several months
and that's a huge benefit for growers
you can kind of market your berries
during the off-season
and provide that to your
consumers plastics can also be very
customizable so you can buy plastics
that block or filter specific
wavelengths of light that might be
important to your plants or important to
the the insects and pollinators that you
have but also for the types of products
that you're applying so kyle mentioned
that nematodes are very sensitive to uv
and that's the case for many other bio
pesticides and also synthetic products
so you can buy plastics that block that
harmful uv
so i'd like to check in with you we're
going to do another poll here using the
same type of program i'm very curious to
know what your business is like so if
you
all right i'm not seeing much more
action so we'll go ahead and cut it here
so it looks like we have quite a few
growers who do grow under low tunnels or
high tunnels and a few that don't and
then a few n a's so that's really great
news to me so this uh talk might be a
little bit of a review for you
but also we might provide you some new
information but for those who don't
render tunnels this might be an
introduction to that the second question
if you stay on that poll
is describe your experience with
managing pests in one to three words so
this is kind of tricky a little bit
challenging but try to think of some
describing words that reflect your
experience with managing pests under low
tunnels
and again you can go ahead and click on
that link in the chat or scan the qr
code to participate
i'll share with you my results when i
get them some interesting things
happening over on mine maybe i'll just
share it with you guys right now i just
don't want to confuse you guys with all
these different things opening but this
is a word cloud um that is showing the
responses and they're lumping the ones
together that are common so we're seeing
hard and difficult not applicable
um we're past difficult use biological
insects so the more responses we get the
more this work cloud becomes interesting
all right i'm not seeing much more
action so we'll go ahead and cut it here
so it looks like there are difficulties
um so there's uh a lot of n a's um
difficulty with wind which is definitely
a problem um more pests more difficult
so hard so the consensus here that
managing pests under low tunnels is more
difficult it's both trickier
than maybe the open field
so the question that we get um
about tunnels is do they actually
promote the presence of pests because
there have been several studies that
report one trend or the other and it
depends on what type of pests that
you're talking about
so we did our own study
recently that's published in crop
protection looking at the proportion and
presence of all the different pests that
you might find under low tunnels on
strawberries so pathogens weeds and
various arthropods
and slugs other invertebrates and we
compared their presence on other tunnels
compared to the open fields and we did
see that tunnels did reduce the
incidence of many diseases so a lot of
foliar and fruit pathogens we did see
that they protected the fruit against
infestation by splattering drosophila
we did see that tunnels do promote
higher densities of two-spotted spider
mite which is a major greenhouse gas
this past really likes warm and dry
conditions so when you give
strawberries a tunnel it provides the
perfect environment for spider mites to
do really well
one pass that was not impacted was
tarnish plant bug oh oops getting ahead
but we did see that they were a massive
pass across both of our systems they're
actually the most important pests that
we identified
so tarnish plant bug i'm sure you all
know about this one um lagus limiolaris
or we call it tbd and i'll call it tbd
going forward
this is a highly generalist pest it can
feed on many different crops and many
different crop parts depending on the
plant and it can provide really terrible
damage on strawberry in that same survey
we didn't use any management techniques
at all we just let them go rampant and
we found that 30 to 48 percent of fruit
had damaged by tomorrow's plum bug and
most of them were unmarketable so that's
a massive cut and yield by
tarnish plant bugs so it definitely
requires some management
there are several options for matching
charge plant bug most people rely on
chemical advances because it's such a
pernicious and difficult pest there are
some cultural control measures you can
do like managing weeds that are
attracted to them and there are also
some really great bio-control options or
using natural enemies against tarnished
plant bug
we are very interested in microbial
biological control of tarnished plant
bugs so microbial could mean something
like nematodes in this case we're
talking about internal pathogenic fungi
so including bavaria or medium you may
have heard of these two different
species but we really like these two
because they've been formulated into
products that you can just buy off the
shelf and you can apply them to your in
your field using your standard sprayers
so really easy to acquire really easy to
apply and in some cases it actually
creates some really great control
so another check in with you guys so
this will require some chat action uh we
call this a chat blast where you take
one minute on your own a quiet quiet
minute um to answer the following
questions but you don't click under
enter until i tell you to so we're gonna
basically explode the chat with
responses
so the two questions i have for you is
how often do you use microbial
pesticides and second do you see
consistent control of pests using your
microbials so let's take a minute i'll
set a timer and then don't click enter
until after the the minute is over and
then we'll flood the the chat with
responses
okay so starting now
all right that is a minute and if you
can
before you press enter if you can see if
you can share your chat with everyone in
the meeting so if you go to the to
portion of your chat try to click on
everyone and see if that works um if not
it might be directly sent to me i'm not
sure or other people um i think it's
still not working sam sorry okay
that's a verbal summary of the responses
you get
sounds good okay then go ahead and click
enter and send me all of your chats and
i will summarize it best i can for you
we have it has been a long time
um not used against thrips which is the
primary target
maybe once a month um in rotation with
other ipm not applicable
occasionally never know
so it seems like uh
yeah either
no no
or it's been a very long time
okay awesome
well maybe those of you who don't use
these uh
bio pesticides or microbials who don't
use it very often
you might have the same issue that we
have
um so the problem we have with these
microbials what kyle mentioned before is
that um they're very vulnerable to uv
degradation but also other environmental
factors but we see that uv is the really
big one
and what happens is there's ambient
sunlight right that comes in through the
atmosphere
it hits our uh target uh spore so in
this case it's the insect pathogen and
it causes the same damage that it causes
to you and me so it actually causes dna
damage in terms of they're called
thyamine dimer so they cause base pairs
to fuse together so when dna replicates
it doesn't replicate properly and it
creates cancers and because the spores
are so so small and their surface area
is much larger than ours
they're much more vulnerable
so the uv uvb rays
can kill them within a few hours if
they're exposed to direct sunlight so
it's a big issue and it's not that
manufactures products are unaware of
they know that this is a problem so a
lot of these formulas have additives
that include uv protectants and
sunscreens
but we do predict that it's still an
issue because even though we still apply
these products we still see kind of
inconsistent results
and we think that uv degradation is
still a problem
so we have the idea of merging our
interest in uv selective plastics and
interest in improving bio control
together to see if you can use uv
selected plastics to improve efficacy of
a specific bio pesticide that includes
bulbaria basiana against tarnished plant
bug
so what we did in the field was we
applied
our product we use micro troll for this
experiment to tarnish plant bug in the
field we use sentinel insects we put
them out there and we bagged them so
they couldn't leave
and we applied this under or we also
applied like uh auger plates so not
including tarsh plant blood just to see
if
you know on our regular auger plates if
the
spores well we applied that under three
difference an open treatment um a wall
treatment and this stupid standard low
tunnel plastic for low tunnel for float
tone strawberry and it blocks about 13
of uvb so it transmits most of it and
then we compare that to a plastic a
thicker plastic and it blocks most of
uvb radiation and we applied this to
both greenhouse and uh field experiments
so we did have a controlled experiment
and then a field experiment
and when we measured sporal survival of
our bulbari basiana we measured the
pathogeny against harsh plant bugs so
often or how more likely was the
pathogen going to kill the insect if it
was under these three different
coverings we also looked at field
efficacy to see if these sprays had any
impact on damage to strawberries but
also the naturally occurring trash plant
bug that you just find on your plants so
the ones that we might not have directly
sprayed but their presence as well
and here's our results and i think ammar
will be providing you handouts of our
talks and this is basically taken
directly from the handout so you'll have
the same copy of this
so the results that we found so when we
looked at spore survival we found that
sport survival was much lower under the
two treatments that transmitted most of
uvb and this included the open treatment
and the dubois low tunnel plastic
treatment and this is what the spores
look like after 72 hours so you can see
that there's only two little colony
forming units here there's a little bit
more for the dubois plastic but we saw
that for the warps plastic most of those
spores survived this plate is covered in
blueberry basiana which is really great
news
we took this further and applied it to
life
tarnish bugs we saw a very similar
trending result so most of the insects
survived the spray when it was applied
in the open fields and in the dubois low
tunnel plastic but significantly fewer
of them survive in the warps treatment
so those spores are doing much better in
the warps
treatment and killing off more of those
harnessed plant bugs
for the field efficacy the results are
less obvious um they we did see that
it's the same trend so we looked at two
different things the number of tarnished
plant bugs per flower cluster
we also looked at the percent of our
fruit that was damaged by tarnish plant
bug and we saw a very supportive trend
that the number of tarnished plant plug
decreased as we increase in our uv
limitation so we had fewer tarnished
plant buds in the warps treatment
compared to the other two
we also saw that yield improved as we
went uh forward in uv limitations so
about 40 percent of our fruit was
damaged by tarsh plant blood which is
still really high
but this was with this is without any
other um
management tactics but it was better
about eight percent um compared to the
open field treatment
and the dupois plastic was kind of in
between
so in summary we did find that bulvari
basiana performed better under the uv
blocking plastics and that resulted in
better control of sentinel insects
but we didn't really see like a very
very strong effect on the naturally
occurring sponge plant bugs so they're
still likely to invade from outside of
our strawberry plots to feed on the
strawberry and cause damage this was
also reflected in the high degree of
damage but we did see this kind of
consistent trend throughout all of our
studies that the blocking plastics did
improve the efficacy of microtrawl the
bio pesticide tested in this study
now i'd like to follow this up with a
very brief um debrief activity so you
can reflect on what we discussed today
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take two minutes um quiet time
to reflect on these two questions so the
first one is what parts of today's talk
were most unclear so what are things
that i could explain a little bit better
and two what would you like to learn
more about this topic and we're going to
share our thoughts not using chat
because it's being weird but we're going
to use the
jamboard function
it's a really fun program if you click
on this link it'll take you
to this live document i'll show you what
this looks like and give a brief
demonstration so we'll take you to this
thing right here and we can actually
interact with each other so what you can
do to answer these questions you can go
and create a sticky note so you click it
here click on your favorite color or go
with pink and you can type in your
answer
all right you click on save and it
creates a sticky note so you click off
of this and this is something i'd like
to know more about so i'm going to move
this over here onto this side
and if we run out of room here there are
multiple panels so you go up here to the
top you can scroll over and there's a
brand new fresh page if you want more
room
let me give you two minutes um to
reflect on these two questions and then
please use that jamboard and those
sticky notes to drop in your comments
i'll go ahead and set the timer
sam while folks are putting their
responses in um we do want to make sure
that we're respectful of people's time
so at it's 1 30 now i'm gonna ask gemma
to post the link in the chat um for how
folks can
fill out their exit survey which
includes um
important piece for getting dec credits
so i want to give people the option to
do that but i would encourage anyone who
is able to stay for another minute or
two to finish out this activity
that would be great
awesome thank you
while everyone is finishing the activity
i did want to thank all of our speakers
and our sponsors thank you to sam kyle
and amara great presentations i hope you
guys enjoyed and learned
some things um
thank you to our sponsors and then
remember to fill out the dec credits
and feel free if you need to go
you can go ahead and hop off at any time
just make sure you do the exit survey
and thank you guys so much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu